so I have a finite series here expressed
in Sigma notation and I encourage you to
pause the video and see if you can
figure out what this evaluates to this
is going to evaluate to a number so
assuming you've had a go at it let's
work through this together so this is
the sum from k equals 1 to K equals 550
so we're going to have 550 terms here
and it's the sum from k equals 1 to K
equals 550 of 2k plus 50 so whenever I
try to evaluate a series I like to just
expand out the sum a little bit just so
that I can I can get a feel for what it
looks like so let's see this is going to
look like when K is equal to 1 this is
going to be 2 times 1 plus 50 when K is
equal to 2 it's going to be 2 times 2
plus 50 when K is equal to 3 it's going
to be 2 times 3 plus 50 and we're going
to keep going all the way until we get
to the last term when k is equal to 550
it's going to be 2 times 5 hundred and
50 plus 50 so let's see this first term
is going to be it evaluates to 52 Plus
this next term is 2 times 2 plus 50 is
going to be 54 plus the next term 2
times 3 is 6 plus 50 is 56 and we're
going to go all the way all the way to
our last term 2 times 550 is 1100 plus
50 is going to be 11 hundred and 50 so
that gives us a good feel for the sum
for the series we're going to start at
52 and we're just going to keep adding 2
for each successive term all the way
until we get to 1150 and we're going to
we're going to take the sum of all of
these and since each successive term
we're increasing by the same amount
we're increasing by 2 we're increasing
by 2 we can recognize this as an
arithmetic series we are increasing by
the same amount each time and there is a
formula for the sum of an arithmetic
series and first we're just going to
apply the formula but then we're going
to get it a little bit of an intuitive
sense for why that formula works and
actually in other videos we have proved
this formula but it's always good to get
a sense that it doesn't you know this
formula just doesn't come out of thin
air so the formula for the sum of an
arithmetic series
so the
of the first n terms is going to be the
first term plus the nth term over two so
it's really the it's really the
arithmetic mean of the first and the
last term's we could say the average in
this I guess everyday language average
of the first and last term's and then
times the number of terms you actually
have so if we were to try to apply it to
this case we're trying to take the sum
sum of the first 550 terms I'll do this
in a new color just for kicks alright so
we're going to take the sum of the first
550 terms and it's going to be equal to
the first term so that's 52 plus the
last term the nth term eleven hundred
and fifty it's really just the average
of those two the average of the first
and the last term and then times the
number of terms we have times 550 so
what is this going to be well we could
simplify this a little bit if we're
going to take 550 divided by 2 this is
going to be I could write this as time
so actually let me just let me just
simplify this in a different way so this
is going to be the same thing as I could
write the 52 divided well let me just
add first so this is going to be 1200
and 2 over 2
all right I do that right yeah 1202 over
2 times 550 now 1200 and 2 divided by 2
is going to be 600 and 1 so this is
equal to 600 and 1 times 550 and let's
see I can multiply that out so let me
just do 550 times 600 and 1 so 1 times
550 is 550 and then I have a 0 here but
then I just have a 0 there so 0 times
550 I'm just gonna get a bunch of zeroes
and then I go to the hundreds place 6
times 0 is 0 6 times 5 is 30 6 times 5
is 30 plus 3 is 33 you add it all
together we get a 0
we get a 5 we get a 5 we get a zero we
get a three we get a three we get three
hundred thirty thousand five hundred and
fifty that's what this whole thing
that's what this whole thing sums up to
now I I just said that will get a little
bit of intuition for why we were able to
just apply this formula and let's just
think about what the sum of the first
550 terms is and I just wrote it down up
here so let me write it I'm just going
to switch colors again so we're going to
have the sum of the first 550 terms
which is what we just wrote over here we
already said this going to be 52 plus 54
plus 56 + and we're going to keep going
all the way to 1150 now I'm going to
write it again
the sum of the first 550 terms but I'm
going to just write it in Reverse we can
obviously swap the order in which we add
it's going to be 1150 plus eleven fifty
minus two which is eleven forty eight
plus that minus two which is eleven
forty six and we go all the way to the
first term all the way to 52 now what I
want to do is just I want to add these
two sums so I'm just going to get 2
times the sum of the first 550 so if I
had the two left sides I'm gonna have 2
times the sum of the first 550 terms and
we do this generally when we prove this
formula in previous videos but I always
like to get a sense of where it comes
from and so this is going to e be equal
to well if I add these two terms right
over here I get what I get 1200 and -
that number should look familiar
and then if I add these two right over
here what do I get I get 1200 + 2 and
then if I add I think you see where this
is going and then if I add these two
characters what do I get I get 1200 and
2 all the way to these last two
characters you add them together when
you get you get 1200 and - so how many
1200 2's do I have well I have 550 of
them there are 550 of these terms so
this is going to be equal to 550 times
into - and so if you just wanted to
solve or for this sum you just divide
all the sides divided by two so you / -
you / - you / - and that's exactly what
we did over here 550 times 1202
divided by two so hopefully that gives
you an intuition for things